when did you first fall in love with
robotics
let's start with love
and robots well love is is relevant
because I think the
the fascination the Deep Fascination is
really about movement
and uh I was visiting MIT looking for a
place to get a PhD and I wanted to do
some laboratory work and one of my
professors at in the Aero Department
said go see this guy mark raber down in
the basement of the AI lab
and so I walked down there and saw him
he showed me his robots
and he showed me this robot doing a
somersault
and I just immediately went whoa you
know yeah robots can do that and because
of my own interest in in gymnastics
there was like this immediate connection
and um you know I was interested in I
was in an arrow Astro degree because you
know flight and movement was also
fascinating to me and then it turned out
that you know robotics have this big
challenge how do you how do you balance
uh how do you how do you build a legged
robot that couldn't really get around
and that just that was a Fascination and
it still exists today you're still
working on perfecting Motion in robots
what about the elegance and the beauty
of the movement itself is is there
something
may be grounded in your appreciation of
uh movement from your gymnastics days
did you
was there something you just
fundamentally appreciate about the
elegance and beauty of movement you know
we had this concept in in gymnastics of
um letting your body do what it wanted
to do when you get really good at
gymnastics
part of what you're doing is putting
your your body into a position where the
physics and the body's inertia and
momentum will kind of push you in the
right direction in a very natural and
organic way
and the thing that Mark was doing you
know in the basement of that laboratory
was trying to figure out how to build
machines to take advantage of those
ideas how do you build something so that
the physics of the machine just kind of
inherently wants to do what it wants to
do and he was building these springy
pogo stick type you know his first cut
at lugged Locomotion was a pogo stick
where it's bouncing and there's a spring
Mass
system that's oscillating has its own
sort of natural frequency there and sort
of figuring out how to augment those
natural physics
um with also intent how do you then
control that but not overpower it it's
that coordination that I think creates
real potential we could call it Beauty
you know you could call it I don't know
Synergy uh that people have different
words for it but I think that that was
inherent uh from the beginning that was
clear to me that that's part of what
Mark was trying to do he asked me to do
that in my research work so
um you know that's where I got going so
part of the thing that I think I'm
calling elegance and Beauty in this case
which was there even with the Pogo
stickers maybe the the efficiency so
letting the body do what it wants to do
trying to discover the efficient
movement it's definitely more efficient
it also becomes easier to control in its
own way because the physics are solving
some of the problem itself it's not like
you have to do all this calculation and
overpower the physics the physics
naturally inherently want to do the
right thing
there can even be you know a feedback
mechanisms stabilizing mechanisms
that occur simply by virtue of the
physics of the body and it's you know
not all
not all in the computer or not even all
in your mind as a person and I there's
something interesting in that melding
you were with Mark for many many many
years but you were there in this kind of
legendary space
of uh leg lab and on my team in the
basement all great things happen in the
basement is there some memories uh is
there some memories from that time
that you have because it's so it's such
Cutting Edge work
in in robotics and artificial
intelligence
the memories the distinctive lessons I
would say I learned in that in that time
period
and um and that I think Mark was a great
teacher of
was uh it's okay to pursue your
interests your curiosity do something
because you love it
um you'll do it a lot better if you love
it
um
that that is a lasting lesson that I
think uh we apply at the company still
um and really is a core value so the
interesting thing is I got to um
uh with people like Ross Cedric and um
and others like the students that work
at those robotics labs are like some of
the happiest people I've ever met
I don't know what that is I mean a lot
of PhD students a lot of them are kind
of broken by the wear and tear of the
process uh but roboticists are while
they work extremely hard and work long
hours
there's a
there's a happiness there the only other
group of people I've met like that are
people that Skydive a lot like for some
reason there's a deep fulfilling
happiness maybe from like a long period
of struggle to get a thing to work and
it works and there's a magic to it I
don't know exactly because it's so
fundamentally Hands-On and you're
bringing a thing to life I don't know
what it is but they're happy
we see you know our our attrition at the
company is really low people come and
they love the pursuit
and I think part of that is that there's
perhaps an actual connection to it it's
a little bit easier to connect when you
have a robot that's moving around in the
world and part of your goal is to make
it move around in the world you can
identify with that and and this is on a
this is one of the unique things about
the kinds of robots we're building is
this physical interaction
who lets you perhaps identify with it so
I think that is a source of happiness I
don't think it's Unique to robotics I
think anybody also who is just pursuing
something they love
it's easier to work hard at it and be
good at it and
um
not everybody gets to find that I I do
feel lucky in that way and I think we're
lucky as an organization that we've been
able to build a business around this and
that keeps people engaged
so if it's all right let's link on mark
for a little bit longer Mark craber so
he's a legend
uh he's a legendary engineer robota says
what what have you learned about life
about Robotics and Mark through all the
many years you worked with him I think
the most important lesson which was you
know have the courage of your
convictions and and do what you think is
interesting
um
be willing to try to find big big
problems to go after and at the time you
know like at Locomotion
um
especially in a dynamic machine
nobody had solved it and that felt like
a
multi-decade problem to go after
and so you know have the courage to go
after that because you're interested
don't worry if it's going to make money
you know that that's been a theme so
that that's really uh probably the most
uh important lesson I think that uh I
got from Mark how crazy is the effort of
doing legged
robotics at that time especially
you know Mark got some stuff to work uh
starting from the simple ideas so maybe
the other another important idea that
has really become a value of the company
is try to simplify a thing to the Core
Essence
and and while you know Mark was showing
videos of animals running across the
Savannah or uh uh climbing mountains
what he started with was a pogo stick
because he was trying to reduce the
problem to something that was manageable
and and getting the pogo stick to
balance had in it
the fundamental problems that if we
solve those you could eventually
extrapolate to something that galloped
like a horse
and so look for those simplifying
principles
um how tough is the job of simplifying a
robot so I I'd say in the early days the
the thing that made Boston
the researchers at Boston Dynamics
special
is that we we worked on under figuring
out what that that Central principle was
and then building software or machines
around that principle and that was not
easy in the early days and and it it
took
um real expertise in understanding the
Dynamics of motion and feedback control
principles how to build and you know
with computers at the time how to build
a feedback control algorithm that was
simple enough that it could run in real
time at a thousand Hertz
and actually get that machine to work
um and that was not something everybody
was doing you know at that time
now the world's changing now and I I I
think the approach is to controlling
robots are going to change
um but uh
and that they're going to become more
broadly yet available
but at the time there weren't many
groups who could really sort of work at
that principled level
with both the software and
and make the hardware work
and I'll and I'll say one other thing
about your sort of talking about what
are the special things the other thing
was go it's okay it's good to break
stuff you know
um you know use the robots break them
repair them
um you know fix and repeat test fix and
repeat and that and that's also a core
principle that has become part of the
company
and it lets you be Fearless in your work
too often if you are working with a very
expensive robot maybe one that you
bought from somebody else or that you
don't know how to fix then you treat it
with kit gloves and you can't actually
make progress you have to be able to
break something and so I think that's a
been a a principle as well so just the
link on that psychologically how do you
deal with that because I remember I had
uh uh I built a RC car
with that some
uh has some custom stuff like compute on
it and all that kind of stuff cameras
and uh because I didn't sleep much the
code I wrote had an issue where it
didn't stop the car and then the car got
confused and at full speed at like 20 25
miles an hour slammed into a wall
and I just remember sitting there alone
in a deep sadness
um
sort of
full of regret I think almost anger
um
uh but also like sadness because you
think about well these robots especially
for autonomous vehicles like like you
should be taking safety very seriously
even in these kinds of things but just
no good feelings
um and made me more afraid probably to
do this kind of experiments in the
future perhaps the right way to have
seen that is positively
like it's it's too it depends if you
could have built that car or or just
gotten another one right that would have
been the approach
um I remember
um when I got to grad school
um you know I got some training about uh
operating a lathe and a mill up in the
machine shop and I could start to make
my own parts and I remember breaking
some piece of equipment in the lab and
then realizing
because I maybe this was a unique part
and I couldn't go buy it and I realized
oh I can just go make it
that was an enabling feeling yeah then
you're not afraid it might take time it
might take more work than you thought it
was going to be required to get this
thing done
but you can just go make it and that's
freeing in a way that nothing else is
you mentioned uh the feedback control
the Dynamics sorry for the Romantic
question but is in the early days and
even now is the Dynamics
probably more appropriate for the early
days is it more art or science
there's a lot of science around it
and and trying to develop you know
scientific principles
that let you extrapolate from like
one-legged machine to another
you know develop a core set of
principles like like a spring Mass
bouncing system and then figure out how
to apply that from a one-legged machine
to a two or a four-legged machine those
principles are really important and and
we're definitely a core part of our work
um there's also
you know when we started to pursue
humanoid robots
um there was so much complexity in that
machine
that you know one of the benefits of the
humanoid form is you have some intuition
about how it should look while it's
moving
and that's a little bit of an art I
think and now I'd say or maybe it's just
tapping into a knowledge that you have
deep in your body and then trying to
express that in the machine but that's
an intuition that's a little bit more on
the art side maybe it it predates your
knowledge you know before you have the
knowledge of how to control it you try
to work through the Art Channel and
humanoids sort of make that available to
you if it had been a different shape
maybe you wouldn't have had the same
intuition about it yeah so you're
knowledge about moving through the world
is not made explicit to you
so you just that's why it's art and it
might yeah it might be hard to actually
articulate exactly you know there's
something about
um and being a competitive uh athlete
there's something about
seeing a movement you know a coach one
of their greatest strengths a coach has
is being able to see you know some
little change in what the athlete is
doing and then being able to articulate
that to the athlete you know and then
maybe even trying to say and you should
try to feel this
um so there's something just in scene
and again you know sometimes it's hard
to articulate what it is you're seeing
but there's a just perceiving the motion
at a rate that is um uh again sometimes
hard to put into words yeah I
Wonder
uh how it is possible to achieve sort of
truly elegant movement you have a movie
like ex machina I'm not sure if you've
seen it but the main actress in that who
plays the AI robot I think is a
ballerina I mean just the natural
um elegance and the I don't know
eloquence of movement
it's it's it looks efficient and easy
and just it looks right
it looks it looks right is sort of the
key yeah and then you you look at uh
especially early robots I mean they
they're so cautious in in the way they
move
um that
it's not it's not the caution that looks
wrong it's it's something about the
movement that looks wrong that feels
like it's very inefficient unnecessarily
so and it's hard to put that into words
exactly we think that and part of the
reason why people are attracted to the
machines we build
is because the inherent dynamics of
movement are are closer to right
um because we we try to use you know
walking Gates or we build a machine
around this gate where you're trying to
work with the Dynamics of the machine
instead of
to stop them you know some of the early
walking machines
you know you're essentially you're
really trying hard to not let them fall
over and so you're always stopping the
Tipping motion you know
and sort of the insight
of dynamic stability and a lawyered
machine is to go with it you know let
the Tipping happen you know let yourself
fall but then catch her catch yourself
with that next foot and there's
something about getting those physics to
be expressed in the machine
that people interpret as
lifelike or or elegant or just natural
looking and so I think if you get the
physics right
it also ends up being more efficient
likely
there's a benefit that it probably ends
up being
more stable in the long run you know it
could it could walk stably over a wider
a range range of conditions
um and it's uh and it's more beautiful
and attractive at the same time